[MUSIC PLAYING]
ISAAC HEPWORTH: Hi, I'm Isaac.
In this video, I'm going to give
you an overview of Apigee's API
monetization capabilities.
Many businesses
have digital assets.
APIs are the interface that
enable developers to leverage
those digital assets.
Such APIs can be
considered products,
with developers
as the customers.
There are many ways businesses
can derive value from APIs.
Exposing APIs can result in
code innovation with developers
and opens up the
potential to grow
new ecosystems around your
digital assets and services.
In some cases, your API
products present the opportunity
to create whole new
direct revenue models.
API monetization is a
key way to unlock value
from your digital
assets, and even
increase API adoption by
building custom packages
tailored to developer needs.
It enables API providers to
reach beyond current business
models and open new
opportunities with customers,
developers, and partners.
The Apigee API
management platform
provides a powerful and flexible
API monetization solution
that is being used by
global enterprises today.
It enables you to package
valuable digital assets
into monetizable products
that can be easily consumed
by developers.
You can create rules to
define which API calls qualify
as monetized transactions and
to enforce monetization limits
on API usage.
If you take credit card
payments from developers,
Apigee makes things like PCI
DSS compliance certificates
straightforward and simple.
Apigee also gives
you the ability
to build innovative
business models
through API monetization.
You can choose from revenue
sharing, usage-based billing,
subscriptions, freemium, and
many other pre-built models.
You can easily create rate
plans and manage renewals.
Apigee API monetization also
supports multiple currencies
and provides for
easy integration
into your billing systems.
Having a monetization
strategy doesn't necessarily
guarantee success.
A developer portal
is often important
so that consumers of your APIs
can quickly and securely gain
access to the tools
and information
they need to explore,
test, and consume them.
A monetization engine should
be integrated seamlessly
with the portal to
simplify how you
publish API packages,
process payments, and meter
transactions.
When your APIs drive
direct revenue,
it becomes even more important
for you to monitor and analyze
usage.
With Apigee, you get
out-of-the-box monitoring
capabilities that enable you
to deliver consistently high
service levels.
Apigee API monetization also
includes detailed reporting
on API traffic based on
developer consumption,
including any
refunds, adjustments,
and service credits.
It offers robust billing
capabilities, including taxes
and international support.
OK, that's a quick introduction
to Apigee API monetization.
If you're already
an Apigee customer,
contact your sales
representative to get started.
If you're not already an Apigee
customer, try it for free.
That's it for me.
Till next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]